we'll be starting in just about 30
seconds
hello to everyone
welcome to everyone on our live stream
as well
all right thank you for your patience
good morning and good evening to
everyone around the world
welcome to our expert webinar the secret
to building great products
and our speaker today is srishti
who
sorry didn't change the title on the
title slide but she is
a vp of
with the
oracle dx marketing group
so
let me move on not mistake two
instructions on how to
make the
webex operation work for you
the q a button will give you the ability
to put questions for srishti into q a
box we will collect those
and i'll give those to her during the q
a section of our presentation
you can use the chat function
um
we
can catch a few questions there but
mostly we focus on the q a so
with that said we'll also be doing
several polls
i want to start with
just one to warm you up
and
this first poll has
two parts
how much work experience do you have
and then
how are you doing today we've been
asking the second part of the question
um all during the pandemic
to let people you know
give us feedback on
how they're holding up under lockdown
and
the various restrictions
and we'll close the poll in about 20
seconds
so have a chance to get your answers in
five
four
three
two
one
and
here are the poll results
so a very even distribution of
experience levels
and
it's good to see that nearly everybody
is doing well or at least okay today
and we hope that what trishi has to
share
will um
give you a brighter outlook so
with that i'm going to introduce her
and
so i said she is the group vice
president of oracle cx marketing
regardless of what it said on the title
slide
um
she is passionate about building and
scaling world-class internet consumer
and sas enterprise software products
so
her
passion is for
making
products that people
find
intuitive and and um satisfying she
provides strategic technical and
operational leadership
to a
a global organization oracle is
worldwide of course
her background is
bachelor engineering from nitk
and mba from university of washington
we're very pleased to have her here
today and welcome trishny thank you
thank you so much uh glad to be back
here and i have this conversation
uh we'll just kick off another poll um
just to sort of you know uh clear the
conversation a little bit better looks
like the experience was quite
distributed let's see what's the uh role
that uh all of you are involved in in
your organizations or you know you know
i guess some of you are students
but let's let's uh
we'll get a sense of the audience and
the group
these
roles are heavily skewed toward
people involved in product
development
you've got about 10 more seconds
and 3
2
1
and
those pull
so the greatest number shirt here in the
other category
management as well
yeah
and
over 10 executives that's interesting
perfect
all right so you know we are going to
talk about building great products
that's the whole conversation uh around
uh and uh and you know let's let's start
with uh
a slide story
so
all right
oh sorry i i forgot the order okay so we
have okay so you know i guess just some
context switching i'm going to talk
about
uh what what is uh you know what is the
secret ingredient to build product and i
really talk about
uh that and we'll disclose it in the
next slide but let's let's do a quick
poll around this do you want to do this
poll then stuart what's up
yes so let's do this but what is the key
challenge you face in product
development
um
as we
look at looking at some of the problems
let's get that sense as well and then
i'll kick off my conversation it's the
last input guys
about 20 more seconds
right
[Music]
you hit that submit button
all right so customer is quite at the
center of it uh and then you know
there's an even distribution on delivery
and stakeholder all right as i expected
thank you thanks for all right let's uh
let's get started then
all right so you know i i think uh even
before i get into what you're seeing on
the slide let me share the story uh back
in early 2000 when i was doing my mba
we were evaluating the music industry
and at the time if you recall what we
all were doing was listening to cds
and that was sort of the form and it was
a strategy paper and we were like what
will disrupt the music industry that was
sort of the
whole research around and if you think
about the music industry there were some
characters in the plot they were the
consumers they were music labels they
were the artists and you know
you know a lot of research was being
done by us in the mba but then he came
along
ipod and itunes right we just had a
product which
it felt sort of you know got that story
right not only did it start as a
portable music player but it very
quickly went into disrupting the
industry by saying now you can buy a
single song right some of you are very
young and this seems very this is the
way of life today but sort of a major
disruption took place now that is
something to keep in mind apple was very
intentional in how they approach their
product development it's really that
they took all the key participants i'm
calling them the plot of the characters
into account
as they built this product
so they wanted to see whether the
customers get what they want which you
know the ipod started out being a
portable player but it very quickly got
innovated into something where people
could now purchase on the go you don't
have to buy the album but it's not like
the artist felt that they were being
left around or they supported it the
music labels also figured out how to
generate revenue so they completed the
picture and that is why you know ipod
succeeded and you know we know the apple
story there there have been a lot more
successes but it's been a story of
looking at the complete picture all the
characters in the plot continuous
innovation
and sort of having that uh intentional
approach if you look at zoom which many
of you may not have heard of it because
it was it failed quite quickly it was a
meteor product right after the ipod and
it added no additional features
or uh you know key value proposition to
any of the important characters in the
plot here right for the music industry
so it came and it went before you could
blink so that's just something uh you
know
to think about as we think about
products which fail and succeed what is
that uh source uh let's let's go to the
next slide
so you know i am going to focus a lot on
this word called empathy and uh i do
believe that uh you know thinking about
the customers thinking about the
stakeholders the market all the
characters in the plot being able to
actually think about something from
their perspective is what i call empathy
and i feel that it is a key ingredient
for success in the product now uh
you know it's not just about uh
i i'm going to talk about sort of
empathy in the product life cycle to me
there are the customers which are very
important and you know as we've
discussed in the poll there are the
stakeholders who are very important and
it's very important to get your team
aligned uh and hand in hand with you for
the vision so that you can succeed so we
are going to talk about the product life
cycle and how empathy plays a key role
in each one of these areas for a
successful product
let's go to the next slide
so let's talk about the customers right
i mean this is sort of should be if it
is not the center of uh your starting
point about building a product
now do we know our customers do we know
what do they want are they looking for
simplicity are they looking for ease of
use are they looking for automation are
they looking for intelligence i mean you
know my last talk quite frankly that i
gave at this platform was all around
simplicity automation and you know that
whole area with what are people looking
for uh are people looking for
performance i mean if you think about
the whole iphone ipod example definitely
ease of use was sort of the driving
factor if you look at
google search as an example performance
is sort of the driving factor there
because the sub second results was what
you know transformed the search industry
if you will right so so you kind of have
to figure out what you want right today
i'm in enterprise software and what we
are looking at is
today consumers are getting used to
simplicity and now the same consumer
goes to work and uses enterprise
software for their day-to-day work what
do you think they're looking for they
also want this work process though it's
a complex workflow they want to do it in
an intuitive and simple way so you know
that's where we bring in some of the
automation and intelligence so that's
sort of a point of view around what what
is our customer looking are we kind of
thinking about them are we you know
being in their shoes uh let's look at a
different dimension right a
non-functional damage what around what
about accessibility right who is your
audience do you need to make sure that
your product is accessible by people do
you think that today privacy is a big
concern right uh you know we've heard of
products fail because uh you know
they're not taking user permission and
sharing data so are you keeping those
non-functional perspectives of the
customer in mind um are you petted
towards their needs about all of these
areas right uh security i mean if you're
not only a financial institute if you
are if you have pii today security is
very important so you know are you
looking at all the aspects that your
customer want
uh the other aspect really is around uh
you know we're building global products
are your products truly global do they
come in different languages are they
supportive of different genders race
language however right so it's it's not
about my customer is one person go on
other days right you sort of have to
look at your customer very holistically
look at functional non-functional so
truly think about
where you want to take your product and
who is that audience and that's what we
uh you know we want to start with as we
think about a product
let's go to the next lecture
so you know uh you know i heard the
statistic right that every one second uh
delay in a page load on a mobile phone
you know adds to 20 drop in traffic for
a mobile web page right so uh so you
know nobody has the patience the
customers don't have the patience the
customers have too many choices today so
if we don't put the customers at the
center and really have some framework in
our organizations if you will uh for uh
for you know
doing product development in a
processified fashion which is keeping
customer the center uh it is a recipe uh
uh for failure so one of such things one
of such a framework is called design
thinking um you know we've been using it
quite heavily i've had some experience
in it um both in terms of sort of you
know when we started the whole
transformation journey for our products
where we were trying to rewrite them
from sort of being complex products from
an interface perspective and a user
experience perspective uh and try to
hide some of the complexity with
automation as well as intelligence and
you know behind the scenes to complex
stuff we looked at design thinking which
is really like a non-linear iterative
framework where you sort of brainstorm
in a cross-functional group you start
out with that you know you meet your
user groups it's a 12 week course which
you know many universities offer you can
find a lot of material around it but the
main reason i'm bringing it up is you
need to kind of have some approach to
make sure that you are not getting
siloed by a particular viewpoint of who
the customer is right so you need to
make sure that you challenge your
assumptions you really need to make sure
you prototype you actually take it to
the customer you test
you interview enough of your customers
or your stakeholders so it is a
framework which sort of methodically
tells you
uh how you could put the customers at
the center so it's one of the many
frameworks but this is something that
you know uh we've been exposed to and it
is something that uh
i been also leveraging sort of even as
training within my team uh whether they
you know people are sitting in the ic
role qa roll dev role
just to get that empathy to the customer
in the organization um uh sort of going
right so this is uh something that i
definitely recommend to check out uh as
as one of the frameworks or sort of
think about it uh let's go i do have a
quick poll uh right after this just to
get a sense from you guys on where you
all are today
even if you you know haven't heard of
the term design thinking
uh i'm hoping that some of you have
you know looked at this approach of sort
of define you know empathizing with the
customer defining the problem then
ideating
doing revs prototyping testing so uh you
know let me know which all of these
methods do you use today
in your organization you feel uh and uh
and you know feel free to put in chat
what what you know what you find
successful
and about 15 seconds left
you know so it's great to know that a
lot of these um
you know at least i don't know if you
know i've seen some chat that you're
saying what is it it's not i mean you
know definitely product managers um can
do it but like i said in my organization
i'm actually having people in all roles
do do uh uh do this uh course because
it's really about at any point you
always have a customer whether you are
actually treating your end customer or
if you are sort of you know an
engineering uh person you you know you
kind of your pm is your customer your
account manager your customer so it's
sort of a methodology which kind of
makes you uh
you know brings in whole empathy and
sort of understanding where your
customers coming from what are their
challenges in so so this is something
that you know uh um is is one of the
many frameworks that you can leverage to
sort of culturally think about uh
empathy and customer sort of you know at
the center of your product development
life cycle
let's uh move to the next slide please
so shifting gears quickly to you know
the next important thing and you know we
spoke about not stakeholder support as
you know enough a few 25 percent of you
talked about that as well
so um
it's it's easy to you know we all talk
about um
you let's have an elevator pitch right
and i think that uh
you know it's gone are the days where
it's the same elevator pitch right again
what i i
am trying to say is that whether you are
an organization large or small you do
need the support of somebody to get your
project going eventually right but who
are you pitching to determines what you
pitch um again share a story right i
when was it late 2000 um i it was the
first time i was moving uh to india from
the us and i was going to be setting up
india deaf center for the company i was
working for and this was an idea i was
just fresh out of my mba and you know i
thought let me do this pitch and and
interestingly i realized right and lunch
lunch as i did it
that what i need to talk about is based
on who i'm talking to right so if i'm
talking to the cto and i'm pitching in
that scenario i'm talking about you know
the talent and the r d uh and you know
how you can get top talent from the top
schools and you know talking about all
of that data points about the top
schools the top challenge and focusing
on that if i'm talking to the cfo i'm
talking about possibly the cost savings
uh and what this can do to the bottom
line and how you know you can build a
larger team maybe at a fraction of the
cost and how this is sort of a great
model if i'm talking to
the sales head i'm talking about you
know how it's in this case the story was
how india is such a large country it's
potentially a great market and you know
as we do private development in the
country we can also go to market right
so my point of this example which is
a pitch right is really about saying
that the pitch is customized because
you're putting on the shoes of the
person you're talking to right so you're
kind of uh empathizing with them and
understanding you know empathy is just
really about
you know being in their mindset right
and then talking to them in their
language that they understand uh because
that's that's your ultimate goal your
ultimate goal is to get the yay for
whatever you're pitching right whether
it's a feature idea i mean it could you
know it could be as small as i want a
new button in this page and i'm trying
to pitch for that or as large as i'm you
know trying to get a big investment to
build a whole new product in a whole new
different country whatever the case may
be
but the point really is can you
customize that conversation
based on who
you are pitching to and that's what
needs you to be very consciously aware
be aware of being empathetic and you
know having that stream of can i can i
think like that person for a minute and
then present not because i have all this
cool data not because i want to say all
of these things i i'll put it in my deck
this picture looks great i put in my
deck no just step aside and you know
pitch what you think will get you that
that's your goal know your audience know
your goal and that's how you develop
your pitch so that's where the
stakeholder comes and is a key key
ingredient in ultimately your product a
life cycle as well
let's go to the next slide this one
and then you know we really need to talk
about uh
building the product let's say you know
you figured out your customers you're
clear about what you want to build
uh you've got the budget you've got to
go ahead and people are saying yes go
ahead now build the product now when you
really have to build the product
how will you succeed right i mean even
in a product development life cycle we
can talk about a tech product most of my
experiences in that uh you know you have
different characters there right you
have the pm you have the devs you have
the qa you have the ux designers you may
have program management project
management i mean there is everything
out there too and if each person is just
thinking from their perspective you have
a very very dysfunctional team very
quickly
you see delays in the project you don't
see uh you know things getting delivered
and and it's
it's it's easy to figure out when you
walk in into a room and you know that
there is a dysfunctional team here at
work right uh if if pms are not able to
negotiate uh and uh you know understand
what it takes to build some feature and
just stuck on feature and time and
cannot cannot negotiate on scope you
probably can't uh you know you can't
move forward if
dev is just you know very focused on
perfection maybe in some states and is
not willing to do iteration uh to make
time to market you know you may not be
able to build a product uh if qa kpis
happen to be you know just let me just
file as many bugs as possible and that's
my kpi because i'm not getting the whole
picture that's a problem now again the
industry has come up with frameworks
such as scrum and agile which try to
break all of this away and they're
telling you that listen we are a team
and you know team is about the
individual and let's let's work together
as a team to ship right a shippable a
potentially shippable product iterative
potentially shippable product is what
you need to
uh deliver but you know a framework will
not work unless the constituents in the
framework as in the team is working
together uh closely and is empathetic
towards each other right so that is
another
very important aspect uh
you know i talk about scrum as a
framework i can talk about devsecops as
a framework which is again you know once
you build a product you need to ship it
out and you know there are all these uh
paradigms now which are making sure that
we don't have walls between us right uh
whether it's you know between dev and
ops or whether it's it is between pm and
queue with scrum but bottom line is that
you know you you need to build that
culture and it's important that you're
you have that notion of
looking out for each other being in each
other's shoe and being able to think
about the problem from another person's
perspective right that is key uh to to a
good team uh set up
uh i know we just flip skipped ahead but
let's blow out that slide squad yeah
this is the next slide
right and then you know to me
ultimately
not nothing is a success unless you can
sort of be the continuous motion right i
mean a lot of us join organizations
where there is an existing product uh
many of us build new products and then
want to make sure that you know it's not
a one wonder
uh ultimately
you you know you are enjoying your work
every day everybody who's coming to work
is enjoying their work every day if if
everybody's feeling that you know we are
being innovative and creating especially
if you're in the product element line
right i mean you want to you want to you
want to be in that
zone
and uh how can you be in that stone is
the key question here right uh and i
think that you know what we spoke about
especially around the customers that
having that customer centricity mindset
across the organization is important
having that empathy around
you know being aligned around that
vision
to say let's all deliver this is
important is important is is is key to
it
ultimately you want to be in a state
where it's not a top down approach right
not one person is coming up with how to
make this product innovative because
development happens in little scrum
teams with little pods you know you may
everybody is building some portion of
the cog of the wheel and then the
product comes together especially when
you're talking about an existing product
and adding features so you want to move
towards a setup where you are
setting up a culture which enables and
empowers innovation at every level and
even that requires you to give that
empowerment to the folks by really
enabling uh you know that empathy and
you know giving them that you know we
have team as we culture let's all be
customer centric and then you get the
ideas and the ideation so uh you know
that's that's another key aspect around
how you can then continue to debate
right i innovation is like one of your
key tenants then
uh
let's go to the next slide
right so ultimately i would like to you
know
end by saying that uh empathy is central
to product development life cycle
whether it's customers stakeholder and
team i mean i think uh
think about
all the characters of the plot to get
the story out
if any one of these things don't work it
will not happen now are there other
things important for product of product
success definitely yes but if you do not
have empathy in
in the picture
it is one of the reasons that it will
fail
right uh you you can price it right you
can have the right feature set if you
can never get it out what happens if
your budget just never gets approved
what happens uh if you build the wrong
product for the wrong customer you did
think about all the various aspects what
happens right so
everything else uh you know comes from
also empathy i mean even even if i go
back to my first example right of apple
right uh why
why they started with the ipod as just a
portable player and how did they
eventually get into let's let's price
the music right let's make it to go it's
really because
it started off from thinking about the
customer and sold a lot of different
problems which is product price
packaging all of that came in but it
started at the center with the customer
and being empathetic to them right so
that is really what it is now today you
know we all know where we are i mean i
recently bought uh an apple watch for my
grandfather right for his 91st birthday
uh which is because now it has the ecg
monitor and the oxygen and you know all
of these things which you know people
are measuring in in the age of i think
the pandemic even more uh so so that you
know they're keeping in touch with the
customer and they're adding features and
functionalities which is called the
continuous innovation right you're
looking at what's happening you're
looking at your customer's perspective
and you're like okay i think they're
people who want to measure their oxygen
level five times in a day um and uh can
i now provide this in my device
so so so it is a model where you are
continuously innovating right
so uh and you're able to deliver in time
right i mean if this product came out
you know two years later now you can
measure the oxygen maybe everybody's
moved up out and you know we are not
interested in measuring oxygen so so the
fact that you know you're able to keep
the customer in the center
to deliver the product in time
really means that you've got your
customer team right and you know
hopefully you know you've got the budget
your apple in this example but doesn't
matter you know it depends on the
product so the key point here is that
you know let's keep those uh key things
in mind as you all take this journey uh
you know i think product development is
a really really large topic and and uh
i'm looking forward to an interesting
conversation with some of the questions
to carry this but hopefully um you know
you guys will take this key takeaway go
back
and think about some of your projects
either the other successes or the
failures
and look at it from this length
as well as look at what you can do
differently if you are in an existing
project today if there is conflict when
delivery is not happening or you're not
getting the yes from your stakeholder or
uh
you know customer adoption is for the
future is not really happening then go
back do the homework and think about did
you really get that perspective that you
know that's that's my key message to to
you guys um i you know wish you all the
success in all the product development
you are doing and i'm hoping that some
of this will help you
in how you uh go through this life cycle
and have that
mindset going forward
thanks um happy to take the questions
now steward and you know continue the
conversation
very good um let me um
pull up the questions because it's
generated a lot of interest okay
and
i guess
one first question is
um
vidcon ask if you could give maybe an
example of design thinking
walk us through
an example yeah so like i said right uh
i mean i can give you an example of what
we did in my team because that's the
easiest for me to do
we were looking at uh
we had a user interface which we felt
was very complex and we felt that people
probably needed to be a little bit more
technical
to
create a campaign and do some messaging
and it was
you know we felt that it was sort of a
little overwhelming from uh people are
used to using a google or consumer
products today right so we wanted to
redesign the interface to make it very
intuitive so that was the problem
statement let's make the interface of
a marketeer sending a campaign very
intuitive uh that was a problem
statement so what we ended up doing is
in this case uh we called a lot of our
campaign services folks and we
interviewed right so so you actually
interview them and you see how how do
you do this process do you pick the
audience first you pick the content
first like you understand how would they
use the product like you talk to them
and then you make some you look at your
assumptions you're like okay any step
can be done first
or do we need a workflow
it's a basic question right uh so and
and some of these assumptions were
clarified because you know we were doing
any step anytime but it probably made it
look overwhelming even though any step
can be done any time and it was
providing flexibility in this case it
was overwhelming the customer right so
we so we decided based on some of the
interviewing say okay let's do a
prototype on a workflow right and say
steps are one two and three and walk
somebody through it and automatically
maybe people think it's more simple
because you think it's three steps
so so it's it's an example of what you
could do so it's really this is an
example of the first wheel which is you
know uh you know kind of making sure
you're interviewing your customer
empathizing with them
prototyping testing the product with
them and going back right so so it sort
of gives you that
nature
or you know a method to do
do this for big or small features right
so that's that's an example
perfect um
we have
a
comment uh in the form of
that
turns into a question from uh vasu who
asks about
a small startup entrepreneur would you
recommend
that somebody
in that situation zeros down in on one
customer segment to meet those needs
and then expands the product out
piecewise stepwise from there
yeah i mean it's a very generic question
and you know it just depends on what it
is but yes i mean i'm not against focus
um and you mean you may understand that
this is your target market you may
launch in a country first and say i know
it's only in one language and those are
conscious choices uh as a startup with
the budget and resources you can make
but the question is as long as you're
doing it with your eyes open right you
even if it's now that segment and that
customer then you're thinking what would
that customer need like even that
customer may still need many of the
non-functional aspects which may be
you know they need the performance in
your product they need the simplicity in
your product they need the privacy in
your product they need the security some
of these non-functional things you still
have to think about you can you can
definitely target the audience in terms
of the market and you can say i'm going
for this segment or this country or uh
you know this age group i i mean
it's your choice completely but i i
think the point i was trying to make is
that think through all the aspects and
then you can make your choices for sure
uh and you know there is always an
iterative development right so you can
also look at it that way but up front
thinking about uh sort of you know the
customer in all these ways is a good
exercise
um
so
gotham has a question that asks how does
empathy go beyond
just gathering customer requirements or
getting an understanding
of
their particular
use
case yeah i mean i i think you know
i guess everybody will say that you're
trying to build the product for the
customer right i mean it's not that
you're not uh it's it's it's and it's
like everybody would always say that you
know i'm trying to work with my team
together but it's it's you know we know
when we work with people and as we are
getting into our own life product
affiliation we get carried away with our
own notions so you may
uh
you know because we get pigeonholed so i
think the main
point i'm trying to make is that keep
the customer in mind and it's not a
rhetoric
it's truly sit in those shoes right and
it may not be you are you know you you
are doing this role you are one of the
many customers as a pm you can't build
the product thinking i am also one of
the customers so you know this makes
sense for me so you know i'm being
empathetic right it is really about
having that larger lens so uh so it is
really around you know expanding that
scope
and sort of making it doing a little bit
of prototyping testing
understanding you know getting up
getting a uh you know you can use a
study you can get six people from like
little bit different backgrounds who
could all fall into your segment but
they're a little different right in
terms of just what they're bringing to
the table in terms of feedback now again
innovation doesn't come by just
listening to them you may you but you
need to listen to what what would help
them and we know apple did that right
it's not like somebody thought
and gave them a prescription that i i
think i need uh to you know buy music
for you know a song for 1.99 instead of
buying a cd for 12.99 but you spoke to
enough customers you realize price is
the problem
and then you figured out how to solve it
so it's not the direct use case it's how
are you able to infer things when you
talk to enough people and understand
their perspective
that's the big notion here
that's a great answer i mean that that
that clarifies the difference between
you know the old style of
oh let's send an analyst to ask about
business process requirements
versus understanding really what
the stakeholders all need um
here's an interesting question from
filezon who asks
um as a student
what are good ways to get hands-on
experience
or skills learning to build a real
product
product development
um in e-commerce for example
well build a shopify site and see if you
can sell things
do it yourself but but you know i mean i
i do think that um
it's again a very generic question uh
but today if you want to do something in
e-commerce you can you know create your
own storefront uh you can be an
entrepreneur on the side right that's
that's an option for you to just learn
right right there uh or if you look in
internships you know you do that route
you can always work for an organization
and learn you can do it yourself uh but
if you are a full-time student then you
know i i do think that today we are in a
world where uh you can you know put up a
stop quite quickly promote it on your
social media and
and sort of get the whole experience
right um as uh as an entrepreneur as a
marketeer as a developer as a
salesperson you can get whatever
experience you want
it's a little bit easier i think today
if you if that's what you want to do
yeah and simple learn has a number of
certification courses if you're looking
you know for somebody who can you know
walk you through the process of
learning those basics and then you can
move on as christie said to
um you know doing it in the real world
but some of our courses
you
do projects that
essentially do the same thing so that
when you go off to do it for real
you have had that uh
experience in the lab so
um
mohamed earphone asks what aspect of
working as a product manager is the most
exciting in your opinion
i think to me um
you know it could be many but i think
it's really about uh
building the product right i mean
actually getting something shippable i
mean it's the whole journey it's the
ideation if you know if you're big on
ideas but i think more than even idea
should even if it was somebody's idea uh
you know to start with if you're a pm
and you're able to touch feel something
that you believe you know you conceived
and delivered even better but i think
just sort of getting new functionality
out there and knowing that you're
solving a real problem for me right it's
like there's a real problem that is
getting solved uh and uh you are
actually helping
somebody's day life
whatever that may be so that that is
really about all products whether it's
you know actual products we all use
day-to-day software products doesn't
matter
yeah that leads into the next question
by the way from
christian who asks uh
how would you compare
the process of developing products
for software in the virtual world versus
physical products
um
and
this particular question also focuses on
um
promotions and and
advertising the product but
from the product development perspective
what do you see as the differences yeah
i mean you know i i should be
fair enough that you know i haven't
worked on a physical product uh myself
right but i do think that the
flexibility that we have
in software
uh
is higher than you would have in
products which are uh which require
manufacturing like mistakes are costlier
there
and
so it's harder to make changes right so
i think the testing the prototyping
research actually probably gets done
with a lot more rigor uh if you're sort
of launching a new shampoo let's just
say or a new drinks product right i mean
there is a whole supply chain
when we are talking about software even
if we you know we thought we had it
great and oh it didn't work out there's
a 21.2 release and then there's a 21.4
release and you can release weekly and
you can release so i think that's the
biggest difference it's an advantage uh
where we can so quickly iterate and pack
out our mistakes right uh which a lot of
the physical products don't have so so
the rigor is a little different in the
physical products a lot more
i could i can also comment from my
experience that
there's a
stage gate product a process in
developing physical products because of
what you said
that it's
costlier and more time consuming to
implement physical production
and so you have to make sure that at
each
step of the development
that you're going in the right direction
and you don't want to
keep going if you get
indicators that
this isn't going to work or that it
won't be accepted by the customers or
there is some production obstacle so
there's a lot of rigor that goes into
once we reach this step of the
development process
let's all sit down review and see if
we've met the criteria to move to the
next step and so that stage gate process
um
it has to be a like you said more
rigorous for the physical product just
because of the
the
challenges and and costs
involved um
so
uh
hold on while i
oh um
aaron
if you could comment on sustainable
product development
and
and i and i don't know what this
question means is it's so is it's again
more got to do with continuous sort of
are you talking about sustainable in
that fashion
generally
he's asking about uh development of
products that
are um environmentally and so this is
yeah okay
i mean again i you know again i don't
have experience specifically on on
products uh for sustainably but i do
feel that
as you know i mean i spoke about
the non-functional requirements and
being
you know for tech products like we talk
about being inclusive similarly as
you're building physical products we are
you know there is a lot to talk about
you know can you build it in a
sustainable fashion today we are you
know from the computer industry we all
are doing a lot of like everything is
moving to the cloud right so when you
look at everything in the cloud it's a
lot of energy and and that's sort of our
biggest footprint if you will right and
and that's where a lot of the data
centers and how as we're getting to the
cloud how can we manage the carbon
footprint with all you know the big data
centers we are opening is is is where uh
you know a lot of the industry leaders
including oracle are now spending time
and energy to figure that problem out
right because we know that you know we
all are quite excited about the digital
transformation and everything is moving
to the cloud but it comes with the cost
of
these data centers and we all now have
to figure out how can we make them
greener so
that's sort of uh you know one point of
view
yeah a couple of things about that
there's a
lovely spot in the
u.s state of oregon
um
and it's up on the columbia river
and it's a very small town that people
wouldn't think of uh
being a high-tech center but a google
data center was built there because it's
next to the bonneville power dam
so there's a lot of water cooling and a
lot of electrical power for running the
data center so
um those kinds of considerations are
interesting how they shape our world and
then the other thing that i thought was
interesting about that is that
the the rise of bitcoin people
didn't necessarily you know you'd
normally think of that as
oh well that's you know completely
virtual and it has no
real world component but then
there's a big the big controversy about
the carbon uh footprint of bitcoin
mining so
it's interesting how virtual and
physical overlap in that respect um we
have a couple of uh last questions one
is from deepak who uh
asks whether certification is necessary
to become a product or project manager
and if so what certifications
should that person go
for yeah i mean i think that you know uh
there is no product management degree uh
as such um today uh you know having said
that i'm actually just right now on the
advisor board for uw for the product
management um center right and and you
know so there is there's a lot of these
courses being done around uh how can you
it's the same thing it's a customer it's
i i you build a product so people are
you know you could come from a degree
which is technical you could come from a
degree which is uh
you know marketing commerce mbas you
know people are it's sort of a
multi-faceted degree and
and then you could look at things
specifically if you're looking at a
product manager right and then it is a
lot of experience and building because
there is no one degree but like i said
like in my mba right we do look look at
strategies
it's all these different courses do you
do product strategy do you look at
pricing you look at packaging i mean
all these aspects the four ps is a big
one for uh product management so you
know there are all of these uh things
that you can um study and train and i'm
sure simply learn has a bunch of courses
as well i know you know there are many
programs which sort of help you uh think
and be like a product manager but
there's not like one degree it's not
like engineering where you know if you
do that you're an engineer
there is not a one standard decreasing
to the degree and you're a pm after
three years right so
experience uh is a key part of being a
pm
eventually
yeah
um
and then
related to that nildo asks
um
their team is developing a new product
and
they aim to provide the team members
with skills
regarding user experience
so are there some short courses or
training programs or certifications that
people can take
with respect to ux and ui
i i do believe yes uh i mean i think i
i i don't know you might you guys might
have something simply then as well i
know google's doing a program now for
user interface and there are many
certifications out there available where
you know you start thinking i mean the
tools one is the tool aspect like how
you use the various tools to create ux
visuals but also um how do you think
about a problem so these are iterative
courses which make you give you a
problem
you know you you have designed this
design that uh you know you can do
courses there design courses in uh even
college today there's school of designs
so definitely ux has uh
is is most
it's more specific uh and it's a skill
which you can sort of go to school for
if you will
and even design thinking we have a new
course and simply learn about that so
we're
one of many alternatives out there but
yeah there's a there's a lot of things
uh if you take a look at
our catalog and catalogs with other
providers
you can find
courses
some of them simple some of them more
rigorous
that can take you to different levels of
skills development in these areas so
i think with that we can close the
questions i want to thank everybody for
asking those
and we are going to go back and do one
last poll that has to do with
the question of learning
so
with respect to different skills of
doing design thinking um
what skills are the people in our
audience today most interested in
learning
adding to their toolkit
and
part two is when would you like to start
doing that
about another 20 seconds
and in three
two
one
here are the results
with the greatest interest being in
product development management and in
business and project management which is
not surprising for this audience
but also ai and machine learning which
is perhaps a little bit surprising
um
so
looking at when people would like to
start
um
about a quarter of everybody says right
away which is always a good answer
if you're going to do
something that takes you toward your
ultimate goal taking that first step
quickly is a good plan so
with that
i am going to thank
christy for being here i will put her
linkedin
information into the chat
and
all right thank you for having me here
uh everybody have a great morning
evening afternoon based on where you are
and um glad to be uh able to uh join you
guys today bye thank you so much thank
you so much for for a wonderful
presentation hershey and for the time he
took with the questions
okay
and
i will just say that we have another
webinar coming up next week
of a different nature this is
aimed more for
people involved at the corporate level
with
their enterprise skilling and reskilling
and
this has our ceo krishna kumar as well
as
the managing director of one of our
partner companies russell kenrick
in the uk
ilx group
so i will again in the chat box place
the information about that
event
and if that is something that you're
interested in responsible for at your
company
and
happy to have you join us for that
for a second while i find it
i'm gonna move on and say you can
connect with us at simply learn at
simplylearn on
facebook twitter
simply learn on linkedin
we look forward to having you at future
events
and
this concludes the webinar i'll keep the
event open just long enough to put in
the links in the chat that i talked
about but i thank everybody for being
here today
and i hope to see you again at future
webinars and in our learning community
you